so the main idea the main way that we
did this study was we image people in
the scanner before and after 48 hours of
sleep deprivation and one of the primary
tasks we use was the one that I just
described
I'll say it again people saw one three
or six letters for a few seconds they
waited seven seconds a probe letter came
up and they had to decide whether that
was one of the letters that had been
presented to them so we gave them the
exact same task pre and post and what we
found behaviorally was that people were
slower and sometimes maybe 20% of the
time they didn't respond within the time
limit and then we image them with fMRI
while they were doing that and we could
look during the stimulus phase or the
retention phase or the probe phase when
they saw the letters while they were
retaining the letters or when we asked
them is that one that you saw what was
going on in their brain the way that we
approach looking at these data is a
little different than other labs so what
we do is first of all we're interested
in what changes from pre to post sleep
deprivation and we look at the brain as
a whole rather than looking at one
particular area of the brain we try to
sign a set of brain areas that are
working together uh-uh
and we call that a network it's not a
network like like a neuro physiologist
would have one neuron wired to another
to another but but because it's a set of
areas that work together we call it a
network so we're looking for a brain
network that reduced its activity from
pre to post sleep deprivation and the
other thing we're interested in is could
we find a network that that where that
happened in every single person and the
thing that we were hoping for is if we
found such a network that the people who
did worse after sleep deprivation we
show more of a loss in the use of that
network than the others and that's
that's what we identified to identify
this brain network so some of the areas
that were the areas that showed reduced
activation we're in the back of the head
some occipital areas and some parietal
areas some of the areas that sort of
maintained activation or sometimes
increased with sleep deprivation because
sort of like a fulcrum this network way
towards the front of the head and so we
identify this network that the more it
reduced its activation for pre to post
sleep deprivation those people who
showed more of a reduction we're the
ones who did the worse so in a sense we
solved the first problem we found
something in the brain that was going on
in the brain that was associated with
differential susceptibility to sleep
deprivation that that was already quite
in advance no one had really had a
handle on that the truth is that it's
very hard if you just look at someone or
talk to them to predict whether they can
handle sleep deprivation well or not no
matter what they tell you then what we
try to do is say ok it are we just
seeing something on imaging or is it
something that really has to do with
people's behavior and that's where we
use the transcranial magnetic
stimulation so the idea was that with
TMS depending on the what you're doing
is giving these pulses of magnetism
pretty intense you can focus what area
of the brain that you put it on and
depending on the frequency you can
either stimulate that area or inhibit
function in that area so we picked an
area that showed reduction post sleep
deprivation and we tried to stimulate it
and our hope was that if we stimulated
that area we can improve people's
performance and we focused on those the
occipital and the occipital and the
parietal areas that were that seemed to
show the most reduction and what we
found which was surprising to me is that
first of all the stimulation to the
occipital area did help people respond a
little faster compared to some other
area that had nothing to do with the
network and the people who benefited
most from that stimulation were the
people who would show the most reduction
in the network which which is another
confirmation that we were finding
something interesting so I found that
quite surprising now it's not it's not a
cure for sleep deprivation it was only
while we were stimulating and while they
were performing that task you know so to
imagine let's say you could really bring
that into real life you know you'd have
to imagine like a truck driver who's
very sleepy having a magnetic stimulator
on there
so I don't think it's really very
practical but it was an idea of showing
that we have this brain network maybe we
could intervene in other ways kind of
things that we thought about if we were
to continue that line of research would
be maybe we could train people using
feedback to actually but using the kind
of neuro biofeedback to actually use
that network more effectively so if they
were feeling tired maybe they could
actually by themselves up regulate that
Network the final experiment that we did
was even more dramatic what we did is we
did the exact same thing we we
sleep-deprived people for 48 hours but
twice a day during the two days of sleep
deprivation they did this memory task
that I described and they got
stimulation to that brain area while
they were doing the memory task and some
people got that stimulation and some
were in a like a placebo group they
didn't get it and we're overall we
didn't see a huge difference between
this TMS treat it was like a drug study
really but using TMS we didn't see a
huge differences between the the treated
group and the untreated group but on
some very specific measures we did see
some differential improvement in the TMS
group and why that's interesting is that
we were the post testing wasn't done
while they were getting TMS so there was
a more long-term relationship
so perhaps getting that for sessions of
stimulation actually help these people
regulate this network a little better